what's the oldest chick you've hooked up  with like probably like 43. nice well  cougar Vibes yeah I was young what about  that what's the heaviest Queen you've  poached oh my God oh I'm not that heavy  though not that heavy  north of lizzo  I'm just trying to see have you dabbled  into bb dubs man  oh my God you know Drake loves BBWs and  you know I've always heard like uh girls  who are certain I think of certain uh  stature that they're they're talented in  ways that this is actually a great  performer by the way oh my God lizzo's  [ __ ] an alien when it comes to just  Talent yeah she's a great performer and  and musically she's incredible like  she's so fire I just I'm just saying I  do know that South though in in my  smaller okay because I know like the  heavier usually they got him in my  experience the mouse game is usually a  lot more uh in my experience is crazy  it's like usually I'm obviously married  now I'm in a relationship but prior to  that you know yeah yeah right